[Music]
yamamoto caputo hi - hi Tanya died more
than my Apple here my getting in
queendom got no the caputo hi Tom young
guy hi guy a like that
yep banquet oh yeah the Nordica
boathouse so we thought on what the
hyper fancy a Pakistani oedema has been
collecting and reselling rare limited
edition street style clothing and
accessories for over a decade in New
York City turning what was once a small
store into a six-figure business while I
old SEMA me go hang all about how you
near Hico lesson why I love me man line
maker my name is Minnie Driver I am an
actress a singer and I am an immigrant I
believe nothing is more American than
its immigrants so I'm teaming up with
great big story to celebrate those that
have come here and left their mark
Oh Jima
his real name is Lam she moved to New
York City and fell in love with American
Street style
waha Kigali mean I'm enlighten Mecca
ya'know family hey Toto Toto tomato
tomahto
todo gul panag motto Tai Chi transect a
super mega party Tom honam's I go party
Tama high type entire group I see so
yanghwa title [ __ ] party kay we saw
Morgan Dante go party ah hey Tony tonic
Dante idea Muay Thai area logo dot Xia
Hou Sango - Jie every party they should
be every item supreme puts out is
limited edition a simple box logo tee
from the supreme store could run you
about thirty dollars but once it hits
the resale market set number could be in
the hundreds o j-- amar was one of the
first to see this as an opportunity and
unique hype was born but the way she
gets high-end access from supreme is a
secret she won't reveal Jana I don't see
new yamani go pot ammonia Tony Caputo
hamada yakichi so you know take my Bongo
you me hi [ __ ] hydrogel Guardian
Gator hi
once the word about ojamas store spread
their business became a huge success and
in 2016 they opened up a hype 2.0 for
special clientele 3:13 go yellow mango
choir is 1800 yeah the higher cost of
him LV and there are some items that are
so valuable
she wouldn't sell them for any price the
idea maybe something will hi-ho to me
how to leave
am i this enough will show another job I
don't want him money
[Music]
Oh Jamar is an encyclopedia for street
wear and she's even attracted celebrity
attention a weekday sale and people ask
me for depict a quick montijo na hitomi
no body
yeah kanui yang come tiger named a sec
cody party second year gotta camco enjoy
edema is very proud to have left her
mark on the retail world and has even
opened up a second unique hype shop in
Hong Kong ma take about ho ho hi ho
pansy Hina yah yah yah yah yah Gator
country
que tal stay accordion like a toga
yamaneika ho chun-yin Oh chica Nico
so koneko yay mommy same thing oh yeah
Jason keeps unique oh yeah that's accent
OH
[Music]